اليمن اين الوضع اليوم مما كان عليه في
ابريل عام
2015 اين هو من الحماسه التي رافقت انطلاق
عمليه عاصفه الحزم ما يشاهده اليمنيون لا
سما في المحافظات الجنوبيه وعلى الساحل
الغربي هو اطماع توسعيه اماراتيه انتقلت
من حيز التنظير والتمني الى حيز التنفيذ
في وضح النهار جزيره ميون وميناء المخا
وقريه ذباب نماذج لهذا التوسع في غياب تام
للسعوديه او في ظل غضه الطرف عن تصرفات
قواه الامارات ضد اليمن واليمنيين الذين
هجرت منهم من تشاء واتخذت من بيوتهم مقار
لها ومن بلداتهم ومناطقهم الاستراتيجيه
قواعد عسكريه وموانئ ومطارات جانب مما حل
بميون واخواتها في هذا
التقرير تقع جزيره ميون او بريم في مدخل
مضيق باب المندب من الشمال مساحتها 13 كيل
مت مربعا ولكون موقعها الاستراتيجي جعلها
محطه اطماع الغزو الخارجي فقد احتلها
البرتغاليون عام
1513 والفرنسيون عام
1738 ثم شركه الهند الشرقيه البريطانيه
عام
1799 فبريطانيا عام
1857 لتشهد عصرها الذهبي مع افتتاح قناه
السويس عام
1869 كمحطات لتموين السفن بالفحم تبعد
جزيره ميون عن ميناء عدن مسافه 100 ميل
بحري 200 ميل عن جزيره كمران وبدا التوسع
والنفوذ الاماراتي في اليمن عقب اطلاق
السعوديه عمليات عاصفه الحزم واعاده الامل
عام
2015 حيث استغلت ابو ظبي انشغال السعوديه
بوضعها الداخلي والمعارك في حدودها مع
ميليشيا الحوثي وقوات الرئيس المخلوع علي
صالح لتبسط السيطره وتتمدد لتكون صاحبه
النفوذ الاقوى
مستقبلا ويكمن الخطر المحدق بجزيره ميون
حاليا في الاطماع الاماراتيه التي تسيطر
على الوضع العسكري والاداري بشكل كامل في
مدينه المخا والساحل الغربي لمحافظه تعز
بما في ذلك مضيق باب المندب الواقع بين
اليمن وجيبوتي وللقوات الاماراتيه قاعده
عسكريه في الجزيره اقيمت من دون علم
الحكومه مكنت ابو ظبي من السيطره عليها
بالكامل القوات الاماراتيه هجرت جميع سكان
الجزيره ونقلتهم الى خيام في منطقه
صحراويه وحولت مساكنهم الى ثكنات لها كما
قام الاماراتيين ايضا بتحويل بلده ذوباب
القريبه من باب المندب الى قاعده عسكريه
يتحكمون بها بالكامل وهجروا جميع سكان
البلده البالغ عددهم نحو 100 الا مواطن
ونقلوهم الى خيام في منطقه صحراويه وفي
ظروف غايه في المعاناه وحولوا مساكنهم الى
ثكنات عسكريه ايضا كما حول الاماراتيين
ميناء المخا الى قاعده عسكريه لهم ووضعوا
فيه نحو 400 من قوات
ومنعوا اليمنيين من الاقتراب منه واصبح
الميناء حكرا عليهم تصل اليه سفنهم
الحربيه وامدادات
العسكريه ونتيجه لهذا الوضع تمنع القوات
الاماراتيه صيد الاسماك الذي هو مصدر رزق
معظم السكان على طول الشريط الساحلي من
باب المندب وحتى ميناء المخا وشكل
الاماراتي قوات محليه تضم مئات من ابناء
الساحل الغربي من الموالين لهم بشكل كامل
ولم يتم اد ابراجهم او اعتمادهم في القوات
الحكوميه اليمنيه وهم يشكلون الى جانب
اخرين من ابناء الجنوب الحزام الامني الذي
تشرف عليه الامارات ولا يجرؤ احد في المخا
على انتقاد الاماراتيين او انتقاد الاوضاع
السائده في المنطقه ومن يفعل ذلك يختطف
ويحقق معه وينقل الى عدن حيث تمتلك
الامارات وقوات تابعه لها سجونا سريه هناك
وتشير معلومات الى ان طلبا اماراتيا قدم
للرئيس المني عبد ربو منصور هادي بان تكون
مديريات المخا وذباب وموزع ومقبله والوازع
محافظه مستقله عن محافظه تعز وتضم الى
اقليم عدن وقد نشر الصحفي جيرمي بيني وهو
محرر متخصص بقضايا الشرق الاوسط في موقع
جينز ديفنس البريطاني الذي يعنى بقضايا
الدفاع والتسلح صورا وخرائط توضح
الانشاءات التي تقوم بها القوات
الاماراتيه في جزيره ميون على مضيق باب
المندب وما يعتقد انه مدرج طائرات جديد
يتم انشاؤه ويتوقع الصحفي البريطاني ان
تنتهي الامارات من اكمال بناء مدرج
الطائرات وانشاءات اخرى بحلول هذا العام
وينضم الينا من باريس صلاح القادري الباحث
في قضايا العالم العربي والاسلامي ومن
لندن صالح الجبواني المحلل السياسي اليمني
سيد صالح الجبواني على اي اساس استولت
الامارات على جزيره ميون واقامت عليها
قاعده عسكريه مع من تنسق يعني الحكومه
الشرعيه تقول ان لا علم لها بذلك ولم
توافق
عليه هو بالتاكيد الامارات
ا احتلت جزيره ميون وانشات القاعده
العسكريه الجويه ثم هجرت السكان وهذا كله
تم معزل عن الحكومه اليمنيه نحن يمكن ان
نقرا التوجه الاماراتي في هذه المنطقه
وغيرها من مناطق الجنوب من خلال زوايا
ثلاث الزاويه الاولى هو ان الامارات
العربيه المتحده خرجت عن اهداف عاصفه
الحزم المعروفه وهي استعاده الدوله
اليمنيه واسقاط الانقلاب الزاويه الثانيه
انه الامارات تتصرف كمالك شرعي
ذو سياده على هذه الارض وكان هذه الارض
بلا حكومه وكان الدوله الشرعيه اليمنيه
غير موجوده الامر الثالث هذا التواجد
الكثيف وهذه القواعد العسكريه وتهجير
السكان هل يقوي موقف المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وهي قائده التحالف العربي ام
يضعف هذا الموقف ويجعله رهينه بيد
الامارات العربيه الم في هذه النقطه اسال
اسال السيد صلاح القادري لو سمحت لي سيد
صالح هل يبدو معقولا ان الامارات نسقت
اولوياتها العسكريه والسياسيه مع السعوديه
قبل البدء بها ام من وراء
ظهرها اظن ان الامر هو من وراء ظهرها لان
الاهداف التي تدخلت من اجلها الامارات في
اليمن هي اهداف اربعه الهدف الاول وهو
اكبر هدف لها وهو القضاء على الثوره
اليمنيه في اطار حربها اطار حرب الامارات
على ثورات الربيع العربي ثانيا الهدف
الثاني هو القضاء على جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين المتمثله في جماعه الاصلاح الهدف
الثالث لليمن للامارات في في في اليمن هو
القضاء وافشال العاصفه الحزم العاصفه
الحزم السعوديه وذلك من خلال ان غرفه عملي
قياده العمليات لقوات صالح كانت من مدينه
ابو ظبي مدينه ابو ظبي بقياده العميد احمد
علي عبد الله صالح ثانيا ان السعوديه بدات
عاصفه الحزم من اجل ماذا من اجل تامين
حدودها الجنوبيه وكذلك اعاده الشرعيه
الرئيس منصور هادي قامت الامارات باضعاف
فكل معارضي منصور هادي احتفت بهم الامارات
وقوتهم وان انشاه المجلس السياسي الجنوبي
الذي مهمته هو ماذا هو الحرب ضد الشرعيه
منصور هادي وكذلك التهديد بالانفصال والسع
الى الانفصال الامر الرابع الذي تريده
الامارات في اليمن هو الهدف اقتصادي وهدف
عسكري الهدف العسكري هو انشاء قاعده في
باب المندب قاعده عسكريه تتحكم بها في في
الجانب في المدخل الجنوبي لبحر العرب
والامر الثاني هو افشال ميناء عدن الذي هو
يمثل اكبر تهديد لموانئ دبي يجب ان نتذكر
انه في سنه 2007 ان عقدت الامارات مع اح
معالي عبد الله صالح اتفاق من اجل تسيير
موانئ ميناء عدن وقامت بتحطيم اقتصاديا
بتحطيم عدن اقتصاديا حيث انتقل من 500000
حاويه سنويا سنه 2007 الى سنه 2011 حينما
قام ب 100 ال حاويه فقط مما اضطر حكومه
التوا كلام السيد صلاح القادري التساؤل
مشروع بالفعل بعد السيطره على جزيره ميون
المخا ميناء العدن دعم ميناء عدن دعم
المجلس الانتقالي الجنوبيه عن دوافع
الامارات منذ البدايه حين مشاركتها في
عاصفه
الحزم هو فعلا يبدو ان الامارات العربيه
المتحده لها دوافع مختلفه عن ما اعلن في
عاصفه الحزمه وه استعاده الدوله واسقاط
الانقلاب حيث دخلت الامارات بكل قوه
وانشات قواعد لها سواء في المكله او في
عدن او في جزيره ميون في باب المندب وصلت
ان تهجر السكان الى الى الصحراء في باب
المندب بالقرب من ذباب الى هذه المناطق
كلها هذا التواجد الكثيف والتحكم بمفاصل
الكيانات السياسيه الهشه في الجنوب وانشاء
كيان ياخذ اوامره من ابو ظبي هذا يدل ان
الامارات العربيه
المتحده لديها اهداف مختلفه عن اهداف
عاصفه الحزم واعتقد ان هذه الاهداف ستشكل
ليس خطر على السياده اليمنيه والدوله
اليمنيه ولكن على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ذاتها ذلك ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ستصبح في وقت قريب رهينه لما
ستمل عليها الامارات العربيه المتحده ذلك
انها تتحكم في المكله حضرموت وهي اهم
منطقه للنفط والغاز في اليمن تتحكم في
مضيق باب المندب الذي تمر منه حوالي 12%
من التجاره العالميه ستتحكم ايضا في عدن
وهي اهم المناطق الاستراتيجيه في اليمن
اذا ماذا بقي للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
انا اعتقد انه ليس مستهدف ليس لحظه ليس
مستهدف اليمن في حسب من هذا التواجد
الاماراتي الكثف ولكن المملكه العربيه
السعوديه سوف تكون الخاسر الاكبر من هذا
التواجد الاماراتي في في هذه المناطق بهذا
الشكل سيد صلاح القادري اذا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه حسب السيد صلاح يا
الخاصر الاكبر من الوجود الاماراتي في
اليمن ماذا عن دول الخليج الاخرى ماذا عن
عمان الذي يقال انها ستصبح مستقبلا ان
استمر الوضع كذلك بين دولتي
امارات احد الاهداف الرئيسيه لم لسيطره
لسيطره الامارات على ميناء عدن هو افشال
ميناء عدن في حد ذاته وضرب الاقتصاد ضرب
الاقتصاد اليمني من اجل لان ال الاكبر
مداخيل الامارات خصوصا دبي عن طريق شركه
موانئ دبي التي تسيطر على 20 ميناء دولي
الامر الثاني هو الالتفاف على سلطنه عمان
حيث تصبح بين دولتي الامارات بين باب
المندب الذي تسيطر عليه الامارات وبين
الامارات كدوله التي لديها جزر للاسف هي
تسيطر على جزر اليمنيه ولكنها لا تنطق
ببنت شفا حينما يتعلق بالجزر الاماراتيه
التي تسيطر عليها
ايران المشكله الكبيره جدا الذي الخاص ليس
السعوديه بالاساس السعوديه القياده
السعوديه اختارت ان ان تمشي في الاجنده
الاماراتيه الخاصر الاكبر الان هو الشعب
اليمني لان للاسف المنصور دي لليوم هذا لا
يواجه الامارات الا حينما يتعلق بوجوده
الشخصي لحد الان لم يقرر كرئيس لكل
اليمنيين ان يواجه الامارات بشكل مباشر
وان وان يستجيب لمصالح اليمنيين هذا الذي
يجب ان يحصل لان الذي تقوم به اليمن
الامارات حاليا هو بدايه هو افشال سلطه
هادي حيث افتعلوا كثير من الازمات من بين
هذه الازمات ازمه البنك المركزي وازمه
كذلك صرف الرواتب للمحافظات الاخرى التي
هي تحت دعم الشرعيه
وكذلك امر اخر هو حينما دخلت القيادات
الجنوبيه المتنفذ في البنك المركزي واوقفت
صرف الاموال التي هي لبقيه المحافظات في
اليمن الامر الاخر هو انشاء ميليشيات
عسكريه في الجنوب وامنيه والسيطره على
منطقه معاشيق هذه المنطقه التي هي كالمن
الخضراء في بغداد القياده الذي هذه يقود
من خلال منطقه تسيطر عليها الامارات امنيا
لتقد ادركنا الوقت اختم مع السيد صلاح
الجبواني هل نحن ازاءه سيطره اماراتيه على
اليمن في الفتره
المقبله نحن الان امام سيطره تكاد تكون
شبه كامله للامارات على مناطق واسعه من
الجنوب اليمني لكن هناك بدا نوع من
التململ بين اوساط السكان ذلك ان السجون
السريه العديده التي انتشرت في المكله وفي
عدن وفي مناطق عديده اوجدت رد فعل سلبيه
اتجاه التواجد الاماراتي ايضا بدا الشارع
السياسي في الجنوب وفي اليمن عموما يتساءل
ماذا تريد الامارات والى اين هذه الدوله
ذاهبه في في الجنوب وفي اليمن عموما هناك
ا بدا حراك
شعبي سيتبلور وسيكبر يوما بعد يوم وستجد
الامارات نفسها في مواجهه مع الشعب اليمني
لا شك في ذلك
الامارات لا تدرك لا تدرك اي اي اشكرك
جزيلا اسفه ل المقاطعه سيد صالح الجبواني
المحلل
السياسي اليمني ضيفنا من لندن وشكر موصول
ايضا لضيفنا من باريس صلاح القدر البحث في
قضايا العالم العربي والاسلامي شكرا لكم
ضيفي كريمين الى اللقاء